Inside our head, we are always alone.
Even when we are with others physically, we
still remain alone in our self.
Throughout life, we often seek things like
drugs to help us numb this feeling of isolation,
rather than eliminate it.
Drugs make it fun to be alone.
They de-familiarize us from our self and for
a little while, we feel what it means to exist
separate from our usual brain patterns.
We become ok with being alone, because for
a brief and fleeting moment, it feels like
we are not.
But we soon sober up and find our self deeper
and more attached to loneliness than ever
before.
So how can we eliminate our feeling of loneliness
and, instead, produce and sustain a feeling
of connection and disembodiment without depending
on intoxicating substances to induce it?
Instead of trying to numb our sense of loneliness,
we must accept and embrace it.
We cannot tap into any sense of collectivity
until we have first embraced what it takes
to exist as an individual.
We must sit with and learn from our loneliness.
We must experience its confusion, sadness,
and pain.
Through this, we can then begin to explore
corners of our self that we otherwise would
never visit.
We can learn from the depth of our lonesomeness
and form it into a unique and valuable self.
We can then use our newfound self to develop
strong and genuine social connections because
we will have developed depth and sincerity
in our character.
We will be able to plug our loneliness into
the collective exchange of life and personality,
and we will soon begin to feel less and less
alone.